[Música]
todos votaram
o espaço de aqui na minha escola de
manhã
esta é minha casa só com vocês também
está aqui aqui duas licenciaturas e
mestrados anda a estudar agora não há
necessidade mas para mim esta é sempre a
minha casa é um prazer estar aqui
convosco
eu vou te falar inicialmente 10 que é o
poder da voz da jornalista
já os anos embora agora esteja ligado a
uma rádio
não vou falar aqui do poder da voz da
rádio
vou falar embora falar da rádio mas
vamos falar a voz à voz lançado o
jurista e diretor do centro de todas as
rádios 900
no primeiro momento quando lançar este
desafio pela frente
eu estava muito atrás
no momento que eu tenho gravado como
talvez tenha sido o momento em que eu
foi o meu primeiro momento da voz
na altura não era mais comum um lançador
de rádios piratas
isto foi há 31 anos com vocês
a primeira emissão de uma rádio que tem
hoje existe
do emissor feito por nós fazemos uma
emissão duas horas e ao domingo às 11 da
manhã à uma da tarde depois da missa
pelas forças antes da missa ninguém
resolvida da mota tinha que terminar ali
deixar o pessoal sair da missa também
para manter os problemas que os culpados
na altura teste foi em 27 de abril de
1986 está quase a fazer 31 aqui
uma rádio que não hoje existe está mais
moderna hoje só tem a comemorar 30 anos
com esta iniciativa o dia 31
já estou ligado a esta regra de qualquer
das maneiras tem sido também fazer
porque o meu primeiro momento em que
estava está reconhecido o meu poder da
voz da voz enquanto comunicador e quando
chegar às outras pessoas
em 1986 quando era um amador da conexão
permite apenas aos domingos das 11
depois da missa
para além da música que fazia rádio com
gira-discos grande outra vez na moda não
é através da música precisa disso ano
outra vez a utilizar o zé mesma definiu
aquela data
logo uma característica terra
além da música o estado paga ter
entrevistas com gente influente lá do
sítio chopada foi o primeiro presidente
da câmara
isto permitiu a rádio tinha pouca
potência não soube informar quando
admite a toyota ser domingo
damos conta dos filhos quando acabávamos
lá as nossas baterias cabos o café e
toda a gente estava a falar daquilo que
nós tivemos sorte em entrevista à
revista que não conseguiam ouvir em casa
não estava aqui era tema de conversa é
que está o primeiro momento que hoje
considero ter sido o meu primeiro
momento de o poder da voz enquanto
comunicador pois mais tarde
a força da voz então rádios piratas das
rádios livros não foi uma força pequena
antes por contrário obrigou a que o
governo na altura legislação sobre a
criação das casas locais e foram estas
rádios piratas cartas com aquela que
vimos houve um só tom que com força o
movimento obrigaram o legislador
realizado na altura que ouvir em todo
mundo através da internet também é um
sinal da força da voz à voz da cadeia
nacional de rádio transmitirá notícias
de lisboa para uma rádio nacional que o
governo na altura não queria que isso
acontecesse e voz
as nossas canelas e não é que veio a
força da voz das rádios piratas
evidente que hoje vocês estão habituados
ao fogo que entrou seja de cima ou
entrava só estava no catar lacrado da
cntv jovens fantástico você na tv esta
entoado chega primeiro à polícia que
acontece você está precisando atacama
estão hoje a internet leva no bolso
nós até podemos lá chegar o smartphone
traz direto do facebook é só comunicar
naquela altura havia áreas
quem é que ouvia falar na cidade
quem é que eu via o presidente da câmara
de viseu da primeira divisão
na antena 1 é porque lá atrás ninguém
ouve homem
estamos a falar de viseu agora imaginem
a força que foi às rádios mudar juntas
por posições em que toda a gente falava
falava padre falava presidente do rancho
folclórico falava presidente do ar toda
a gente começou é falar na rádio e
escutasse de rádio que era uma coisa
impensável foram as rádios locais das
rádios piratas jogadas libera dessa
força evento estamos atordoados as
diretas fazer um directo aqui há 30 anos
é uma trabalheira três caminhões e um
carro para fazer aqui um programa na
televisão no rádio hoje legais parte
forma já fazer um directo
e hoje é nossa voz à voz de cada um de
nós jornalistas ou não temos poder ou
ficamos lei todos para mim damos a todos
entretidos em minha voz a minha
fotografia no facebook está no poder em
todo o nosso país da nossa volta mas
milhões e agora focando um cadinho no
jornalista e naquelas jornalistas vocês
vão ser daqui uns anos
nosso maior desafio hoje é sermos mesmos
juristas sendo os publicitários ser
mulher p
othon achamos mais um
isso é muito comum para jornalistas é
uma coisa que vem na internet está tudo
armado e nem vemos aí é que está o nosso
poder da nossa voz não fala mais um com
alguns amigos o facebook não controla a
internet só sabia
eu não sou jornalista ter poder
não gosto do quarto poder e às vezes não
sei se é o quarto poder ao seu poder do
quarto
não misturo isso que o jornalista não
deve ser um texto não temos certezas
qual é o nosso poder o poder da nossa
voz não deve nos pode vir a informação
que vale nada
eu que tem segurança para o consumidor a
senhora facebook e portanto de cana na
internet importante na nossa voz
nós poder dos nomes terra lhe dar mais
informação
nós damos para isso criamos contextos
país
temos capacidade para isso
e depois o outro outra questão também
não deve nosso poder da nossa voz para
dar mais voz às proposições ser uma voz
que não se cala e aqui queremos puxar o
outro sítio que o jornal do centro foi
criado há 15 anos foi a primeira capa
sou diretor desde março de 2014 esta foi
a capa do álbum porque eu vou buscar
esta tarde estando a voz e o poder a sua
voz para composições
somos tranquilos em todo o distrito e
aqui está o poder e acho que o nosso
poder o poder da nossa voz dos juristas
é dar voz às pessoas que não têm
nós temos notícias exemplo dos 25
consciente somos orgulhosamente
regionais a conceitos neste distrito
esta política de material nunca tiveram
tanta notícias que nestes últimos três
anos nós temos todas as todas as semanas
a notícia fez apresentar o jornal numa
universidade não vou dizer qual o
investigador está na bélgica quando eu
disse isto que todos em todos ou em
todos os números havia edições notícias
do concelho mais penas a chutar o chão
faz um tenso pela mais informações
aconselho não tem notícias não consegue
dar a informação com valor e eu disse
não é que uma breve um concelho pequeno
é tão ou mais importante que o meia
página não conseguiram as pessoas do
meio do ano quando abre os jogos em tv e
uma pequena notícia só consegue ficam
todos satisfeitos não muito importante é
estúpido grandes página dos dois
concelhos
a empresa regional
eu sou orgulhosamente o jornalista
regional
sou orgulhosamente diretor do jornal
sou orgulhosamente diretor de uma rede
regional tem orgulho do barulho na para
qualquer lado a lado os jornais
nacionais sem vergonha de um jornal
regional de final
sou eu
o poder de voz da nossa imprensa
regional é dar voz não chegou a disputar
o modelo dos 900
[Aplausos]